die beiden impfstoffe die jetzt am
weitesten vorangekommen sind in der
erprobung sind beides messenger rna
impfstoffe das ist ein ganz neuer typ
von impfstoff den es bisher noch nicht
gab
die wirken ein bisschen anders als
herkömmliche viele herkömmliche
impfstoffe sind so aufgebaut dass man
von einem virus einen bestandteil ein
protein genommen hat das hat man in
großen mengen hergestellt in den
impfstoff getan
das spritzt man es wird im körper als
fremd erkannt die immunreaktion kommt
und drängt dieses material und damit
aber auch echte viren zurück jetzt wird
stattdessen mit einem gen gf dieses
gehen kommt in den körper rein und die
körper zellen produzieren dann selber
diesen fremdstoffe ab dann ist wieder
alles genauso wenn der fremd stoff da
ist erkennt ihn das immunsystem und
reagiert mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schaut euch hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren